[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous savez il a perdu son premier procès
gagner le deuxième donc c'est
sa vie privée en fait très vite moi je
me suis dit on n'aura jamais la réponse
on peut pas se positionner comme
procureur ou comme juge malheureusement
sa vie est très exposée et il fallait
faire avec mais je suis partie du
principe ça ne me regardait pas celui
qui reprennent goût au métier de
d'acteur
[Musique]
évidemment c'est le record de calme mais
je n'ai pas forcément envie de dire
c'est formidable on voit les films on
regarde on en parle ce qu'il y a de
formidable c'est que la présence
l'importance grandissante
des réalisatrices dans le cinéma fait
que plus évidemment qu'avant et comme en
littérature ou en musique le regard
féminin les histoires féminines vont
arriver d'une autre manière dans le
monde du cinéma
[Musique]